Salut à tous c'est les Pêcheurs de Trésors
Salut !
Aujourd'hui on va pêcher à l'aimant dans un coin plutôt pas mal, vous avez un pont ici
Une petite route passante
De l'autre côté
Rasta commence déjà à prendre ses marques
Nous on va commencer et voire tout de suite ce que cache ce cours d'eau
Je pense avoir quelque chose pour mon premier lancer
Ah bah oui
Alors nous avons
Il embête le monsieur là bas Rasta
On a une partie de pédalier de vélo
Qui semble très ancien
C'est quand même un petit village isolé, il devrait y avoir pas mal de choses anciennes
je ne pense pas que cela ait déjà été fait
Et je sent l'aimant qui a frotté sur plusieurs choses
Donc nous allons voir
C'est bon tu as ramené Rasta ?
Alors qu'est-ce qu'on a ? Encore quelque chose
Un bout de tube
T'as trouvé quoi ?
Une sorte de bèche
Ah même pas, il y a des dents
Elle est cassée
Ok ouais un outil ancien
Ouais tu vois ça a l'air bien ancien ici
Ouah
J'ai enlevé la boue, elle est arrivée pile sur ta chaussure
Oh non...
Désolé
On dirait que ça vient, c'est lourd
C'est peut-être un barbecue effectivement, sous ces ponts on fait souvent des barbecues
Ou alors c'est une branche
Non, c'est un panneau
Il a l'air gros parce que il est lourd
C'est à cause de la vase ça
Il a été jeté récemment on dirait
Et bien voilà
Bravo
Très beau panneau
Il était peut-être juste là car il y a des travaux là haut
Enfin c'est  pas des travaux c'est la barrière qui est casséee
ça c'est des vieux freins de vélo je pense
il y a quelque chose d'autre qui est retombé
On va voir ce que c'est
Oh elle est belle
Elle a une forme sympa
Ah ça c'est un opinel
Enfin ce qu'il en reste
Fallait le reconnaître
Je préfère le mien d'opinel
regardez
Pour moi ça ce n'est pas en fer, il y a un tout petit peu de matière aimantées
Je crois que ça vient d'une lampe à huile
Si vous savez en commentaires n'hésitez pas
Ah une chaîne
ça c'est un morceau de couteau aussi
regarde
fais voire le tiens
Le mien est un économe
Ah oui
regarde cette chaine, elle est super ancienne
je ne sais pas à quoi cela servait
Peut-être que c'est agricole
Pour ceux qui se le demandent, nous utilisons toujours les aimants barbarian 1600 kg de chez Maison de la détection,
Si vous souhaitez vous équiper, on conseille en général un aimant tel que le Terror ou le double face 880 kg
Qui permettent déjà de faire de belles découvertes
On le rappel aussi, le code promo PECHEURDETRESORS
Offre 5% sur toute la boutique, y compris les détecteurs de métaux
On va regarder
A chaque fois, je suis à deux doigts de tomber ici
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Un pot
Un pot de fleur troué
Tant qu'il y a quelque chose à chaque lancé, ça me va
Ca me va très bien
Comment ça va Monsieur Dimunch ?
Mon petit Rasta
Il est très sage aujourd'hui
A part quand il va embêter les touristes hollandais
Il a le droit
Il y retourne ....
Là j'ai quelque chose
Une munition
Calibre 12, pleine
Sympa, c'est du petit 12, celle là a l'air assez ancienne
Peut être qu'il y a le fusil à pompe avec
Vu la cartouche, ça serait plutôt un fusil de chasse
On va voir
Rasta ne fait que d'embêter les touristes
Rasta, viens ici
Ne serait-ce pas un très jolie cadenas ancien ?
J'ai bien l'impression que oui
Super
Ils vont mettre Rasta dans le panier, à l'avant du vélo
Il va retourner aux Pays-Bas
Ah ! Ca c'est bien, une paire de ciseaux
Rasta qui fait sa petite baignade dans le canal
Viens ici ! Allez viens !
J'ai trouvé un piquet de péniche
Oh, une pièce
1 centime de franc, 1969
Pas mal
C'est cool
Oh, j'ai fais un vieux cadenas comme le tien
Un vieux cadenas aussi
Il est ouvert le mien
Rasta, ils sont partis tes copains
C'est original
Un amas de bouchons
De limonades
Ils se sont solidifiés
Franchement, c'est de l'art
Comment ils ont fait ça
Tu vois qu'ils ne sont pas jeunes
Je pense que c'est à l'époque, avant de jeter des canettes, ils jetaient des bouteilles de bières comme ça
Vous voyez les gants, à chaque fois
Trois ou quatre utilisations et ca part déjà en vrille
Après vous vous moquez de nos gants
On en va pas changer à chaque fois
Sinon l'action de dépollution va se perdre à force d'acheter des gants en plastique
On aura une emprunte carbone plus élevée
Oh la quantité !
Une vieille clef
Qui a l'air très belle
C'est recherché ces vieilles clefs
La bassine on va la recoller pour l'avoir en entier, il y a même la anse
Regardez la pièce !
République Française, c'est 1 franc non ?
2 francs !
Regardez comme elle ressort bien après quelques frottements
On a donc une pièce de 2 francs de 1982
Plutôt cool
Regarde
Tu crois qu'ils vont ensemble ?
Oui c'était dessus
Vous nous direz quel type d'alternateur ça peut être
Tu as une poche pour les pièces ?
Est-ce que je pourrais également mettre cette clef avant qu'on la perde ?
Non
T'es vraiment pas très sympathique
Il y a un truc bien là
Laguiole ?
Ouais, il est super beau
Il fait tire-bouchon
Il est superbe
On dirait un filtre à café
Ouais, ou a thé
Joli !
Je ne vais pas toucher la lame pour l'instant, il faudra faire doucement
Mais il est superbe
Si vous avez une idée aussi pour ce boue de ferraille
Il y a pas mal de choses quand même
On est sur un endroit ou les péniches se garent
Ils viennent manger sur le bord
Il peut y avoir pas mal de choses
C'est lourd
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Vous faites quoi là ? Ce n'est pas l'heure de la pause
Rasta !
Juste 5 minutes ...
Mais il ne fait jamais rien lui ! Il ne jete jamais la corde
Mais 5 minutes ...
Oh regardez !
Celui qui a le meilleur truc a gagné
Un fer à cheval
Ne t'inquiètes pas
Un ressort, plutôt intéressant
Mais à part ça, je crois qu'il a gagné avec son fer à cheval
Une pile
Ca n'a rien à faire dans l'eau
Premier leurre de la journée
Et une pièce
5 centimes d'euros ? Oui
C'est lourd !
Une sorte de poignée
Un petit piquet
Et de la vieille ferraille
Une sonnette de vélo
Je pense
Elle ne marche plus trop
Ah ! Ca brille
C'est un bracelet
Bracelet de montre ?
Un bracelet de montre cassé je pense
Ouais, plus qu'à trouver la montre
Il y en a un qui devait être dégouté
Il ne faut jamais croiser les aimants
Tu as tiré après
Faut regarder le ralenti parce que je ne suis pas sûr
On vous le met
A cause de toi je n'ai rien remonté
Une fourchette aux algues
Celle là, Quentin mange avec ce soir
Pendant la pause de pêche, on a fait une petite cueillette de poireaux
On a clairement le repas de ce soir
Il y a des poireaux de vigne de partout ici
Allé, on va passer de l'autre côté du pont, là bas
Pour faire vraiment sous le pont cette fois
Ah, une conserve
Ah mais l'endroit a déjà été fait
Il y a un parasole Lou Canalou qui a été pêché
Il a trouvé une balle
Ah ! Une chaise de pêcheur
Elle est énorme
C'est un transat de pêcheur
Ah ouais c'est un XXL
Celui là ne devait pas se lever beaucoup de sa chaise
Il devait se taper des siestes au bord de l'eau
5 centimes de francs !
Elle est super bien conservée encore une fois
De 1962
Oh, c'est vieux !
Rasta, la balle !
Tu fais les bêtises
Si vous êtes nait en 1962, dédiasse à vous
La corde
Oh non !
Tu l'as jeté dans l'eau
Vas-y, prends là
Voilà, allé c'est bien
Non ! Il l'a jeté exprès
Le pauvre
Prends lui
Dernière fois alors
Tiens mon petit
Non, non ! Arêtes ...
Tu fais exprès Rasta ...
Je ne la récupère pas
Il a encore essayé
C'est un morceau de tube
Dommage. Il a une forme assez spéciale
Après trois ans de pêche à l'aimant j'ai fais une pièce de 1 euro !
Se sont des pièces qui n'accrochent pas je crois de base
Elle a un tout petit peu de ferraille autour
J'ai pu avoir cette pièce de 1 euro
C'est étonnant, elle est vraiment légère
J'ai presque l'impression que c'est une fausse
Fais voir
C'est difficile d'avoir la notion avec les gants, je pense qu'elle est normale
Oui !
C'est un tomahawk ?
Manche en bois ?
Non
Il est incroyable !
Je suis obligé de le tester
Non ...
Ah non, pas assez aiguisé
On va le restaurer
Mec, il est incroyable
Le manche est en plastique
Il est en fer et plastique
Stylé !
Belle forme
C'est ma meilleure trouvaille de la journée
En réalité, c'est toi Rasta qui nous jette la balle
Arrêtes de la mettre dans l'eau, d'accord ?
Allé, tiens
Regardez ce qu'il va faire
Il va aller directement la mettre dans l'eau
Oh mince, il l'a faite tomber
Après il pleure
Il est fatiguant
C'est décide, on met Rasta en vente aux enchères
Proposez un prix un commentaire
L'abonné qui a le plus de j'aime le gagne
Ah, bravo
Arrêtes Rasta, quand même
Voilà, un petit couteau rond
Les jaloux diront que c'est un couteau à beurre
Les vrais diront que c'est une arme de meurtre
En plus il y a une marque, vous voyez, ce n'est pas n'importe quoi
On n'est pas là pour déconner
Chanceux !
Au même endroit ?
Ouais, il a du les jeter
Par là
Restaurable, ça peut être très joli
En bon état, elle n'est pas très vieille
Bon état, c'est vite dit quand même
Je fais une dernière remontée et on va se quitter
Ouais je pense qu'on va arrêter là, il va faire nuit
Rien
A la semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle vidéo de pêche à l'aimant